So welcome everyone to lecture number
seven of the course. We are now in the
more or less bang in the middle of the
of the course. There are 14 lectures and
this is seventh one. So after today
we'll be really at the halfway point.
Okay. So let's get back to what we have
been trying to do. So our aim has been
to learn PTEs and to that end we want to
use neuronet networks or machine
learning AI whatever you call it and now
we have shifted focus in the last couple
of lectures towards operator learning.
So the idea is that we want to learn not
just u the solution of PD at points in
space and time but the entire PD
solution operator right and we want to
learn this from data. So this is the
setup that uh we have been dealing with
and because this is essentially an
infinite dimensional setup. So the whole
thing is infinite dimensional
but all computations are finite
dimensional. So we somehow have to
bridge the gap or take things in
infinite dimensions come back to finite
dimensions or take things in one
dimensions and go up to infinite
dimensions. And there are two
possibilities uh or two broad frameworks
to do that. And I have covered both of
them to some extent. The first is that
you discretize and then learn. So you
have something in infinite dimensions.
You want to project it down to finite
dimensions. Use neural networks and then
lift up to infinite dimensions. Right?
So that is the basic uh setting and
there we we've argued that the or we
discovered that the most uh let's say
naive no perhaps not naive but let's say
the most canonical way to do it would be
to sample on a grid use CNN's so that
you have sparity you have spatial
structure and then interpolate back to
infinite dimensions now this was an
effective approach in some sense but the
issue was that it did not understand
that we're actually discretizing or
we're learning functions or operators
rather and the inputs and outputs are
functions. It just uh sort of realized
them as vectors. So as a consequence we
did not generalize across grid
resolutions. So this was the end of that
approach to some extent right because we
want generalization across grids because
that's a important uh sort of element or
requirement for operator learning. So
the alternative then we said is that
instead of first uh projecting down to
finite dimensions doing our learning
what about lifting to infinite
dimensions and then doing our learning.
Now this leads to neural operators right
so this is what I introduced in the last
lecture and within neural operators fn
fia neural operator is a prominent
example. So let me just quickly recall
what we do in fn. So the idea is that
you have a function um a FIA layer and
input which is a function on a grid for
instance you take a FIA transform you do
multiplication in FIA space which is
convolution in physical space you take a
inverse FIA transform and then you come
back to physical space and then you
apply pointwise nonlinearity so this was
sort of the throughput of an FNO and the
advantage is that you can do it with an
FFT so it's fast at least on cartition
grids so this was well and good but
unfortunately perhaps it was better than
the naive approach at CNN's but we also
realized that this did not generalize
across great resolutions right so
whether we learned and discretized or
discretized and learned the end result
was the same there was no obvious
generalization across great resolutions
and then towards the end of last lecture
where I hured up a little bit we
analyzed this entire phenomena this
entire all these observations under the
prism of what are called reenos or
representation equivalent neural
operators and let me just quickly recall
what reinos are. Uh we we saw them at
the end of last lecture. The idea is
that we have essentially an infinite
dimensional problem. So your G your
script G if you want to say or
calligraphic G is a operator. So it
takes function inputs and churns out
function outputs. Right? So this is the
basic setting. But we cannot compute in
infinite dimensions at least without
digital computers. we have to go down to
finite dimensions and sort of discretize
the problem. So then you have to work
with finite dimensional inputs and
outputs. This could be on grid for
instance functions on a grid. It could
be elements of a basis whatever finite
dimensional representation that we have.
And uh we can always go back and forth
between infinite and finite dimensions
using this encoding and this
reconstruction operators or you can
think of encoding as sampling and
reconstruction as um uh essentially
interpolation. It could be something
else as we'll find out. Right? So there
is this infinite dimensional world and
there is a finite dimensional world. And
the key point is that the infinite
dimensional representation and the
finite dimensional representation these
should be tightly coupled to or related
to each other. And this was the whole
point of uh this framework which says
that whether you learned or discretized
or discretized or learned these things
should commute. They should be exactly
the same and this is measured in terms
of what are called aliasing errors.
Right? So aliasing errors tells you that
when you take a finite dimensional
representation of an infinite
dimensional object, you could end up
with some errors and these errors should
be zero because otherwise they will add
an additional layer of errors to your
system. And as I said, this was proposed
uh by Francesca Baraluchcci and from my
lab some years ago and the basic idea is
that we minimize this or not minimize
but we make this zero right to make it
completely structure preserving and we
do it for every layer. So just like in
FNO you have this multiple layers for
each of these layers we demand or we
require that the aliasing error is going
to be zero the finite and the infinite
dimensional representations are tightly
coupled they are exactly the same and
this led to the concept of Reno or
representation equivalent operator
because if we have a then there is
whether we work in final dimensions or
infinite dimensions there's no issue
whatsoever right and then we realize
that once we do that and this was my
concluding slide in the last lecture
that uh then we can seamlessly move
between grid resolutions because these
are different representations of the
same same underlying function or same
underlying operator. I don't want to
repeat that. We took these two diagrams
and we combined them and then there was
this automatic formula that came up
which if these uh diagrams are computing
right if they are not commuting if there
are errors then you cannot do that but
in case there are no errors the aliasing
error is exactly zero then what we
realized is that in that case we we can
move between different representations
or different resolutions. This is a very
very general abstract framework. But the
point is that this is still an abstract
framework. It has some symbols, right?
It has a function space symbol. It is a
discrete space symbol. We have to sort
of flesh it out. We have to make it more
concrete. And this would be the first
objective that we are going to do now.
So this was just a recall of what we had
in the last lecture. Let me start with
some examples and then you'll see for
yourself how these things can be
concretized or instantiated.
Okay, so let me give you a so remember
that this is the picture that you always
have to keep in the back of your mind.
So you have some infinite dimensional
spaces. The operator is mapping between
infinite dimensional spaces. This is
usually given to us, right? It's not
something that we have choice on. This
is the setting of your problem. Maybe we
can make some approximations, maybe not.
We we have to see that. But what we have
in our choice is how we discretize
because this is the intrinsic problem.
The underlying problem is a finite
infinite dimensional one. But we make a
discretization. We propose a finite
dimensional setting. So this X and Y and
this R and E these are somehow under our
control. We can always sort of devise
them ourselves. So let us take one
concrete. There are many many examples
that you can take. Let me take one one
concrete example just to flesh this
entire concept up to exemplify it.
Right? So just for simplicity this can
be done on very very complex geometries
but just in 1D so that everything is
clear and on a regular grid so
equidistant grid this is what it means.
So perhaps the way we can think of it is
let me draw some pictures.
So let's say that we are between 0 and
one and we draw a grid on it and we have
some underlying function.
So this is your input and you can
imagine that the output in is on a
similar grid. Right? So now what will be
my function spaces? They can be
continuous functions. They can be solef
functions. They can be holder continuous
functions whatever. But I will take very
specific class of functions because they
have some very nice properties and these
are what are called band limited
functions. So if you do signal
processing or harmonic analysis in
mathematics, signal processing and
engineering one often deals with band
limited functions. So what are band
limited functions? Band limited
functions are those functions which are
first of all square integraable. They're
in L2. So you can take a FIA transform,
right? So you can take a FIA transform
and then you require that their FIA
coefficients beyond a certain band are
equal to zero. And this band can be very
large. This can be - 10,000 to 10,000 -
10 million to 10 million. But
essentially there is a finite band.
Okay. And the idea is that uh and you'll
see that in PDEs this is uh perhaps too
harsh an assumption perhaps not we will
we'll look at it later in the lecture
today but essentially what you say is
that the frequency content beyond a
certain finite band of frequencies is
zero. So that's all that that is just
imagine so if you want on a on a
periodic domain this is you can express
any function in terms of s and cosiness
essentially. So you can think that you
can represent it as a finite number of
signs right. So sin 10,000x the
coefficient sitting in front of it would
be zero and anything beyond that. So
these are very very general functions as
I said they come up very frequently in
signal processing. So when I'm talking
to you my voice if I represent it as a
signal would have the high frequencies
would be so small that I can I can
neglect them. Right? Humans can't anyway
hear right anyway for us between 20 Hz
and 20,000 htz is our audible range
beyond that it doesn't matter to us so
even if a signal has 50,000 htz we can't
listen to it anyway so this is a
reasonable assumption we are going to
question that in a minute but let's
let's keep it as it is so imagine that a
function can be written in terms of a
4year series but the very very high 4
year coefficients are zero okay so this
is band limited functions now it turns
out that for band limit limited
functions. So this X and Y are band
limited functions. Okay. So you take a
mapping which takes band limited
functions to band limited functions but
they need not be on the same band
that that that could be possible. Now it
turns out in this setting there's a very
nice mathematical sort of intuitive
engineering theory that exists which
goes back to Shannon as many many other
things. Right? So first of all what is
the encoding? Encoding is taking some
function which is infinite dimensional
and uh realizing it or projecting it
down to finite dimensions. In this case
the encoding is precisely the pointwise
sampling. So you can just sample it on a
grid. So instead of having the function
uh values of the function you can just
tell me that this function is
represented by values on a grid. Right?
This is what we tried to do anyway. We
just took a function and we sampled it
as values on a grid. If you want to
think those who know finite elements,
you can think that your function is not
living in an infinite dimensional space
but it's living in a very high
dimensional finite element space and
these are the coefficients of the finite
element basis. This one way of thinking
about it. Okay. So this is pointwise
evaluation. That's the encoding. But
this is so given a function in infinite
dimensions you just read out its values
at these points at these grid points.
But what if you have been given the grid
points and you go back to infinite
dimensions what happens? So this is this
part right this reconstruction. So in
this case the reconstruction is given in
terms of a basis. So it's an
interpolation you can call it. It's
given in terms of a basis which is given
by sync functions. Okay. What is sync
functions? You know what is sync? Sync
is sin of 2 pix over 2 pix or something
like that. Right? This is a basic sync
function. But you can sort of scale
them. You can take them at different
frequencies and you can put them
together. So this is the this is the
representation. So you take sync
functions you take you weigh them
against the function value and that
gives you a function and this is
precisely going to be a reconstruction
operator. Okay for finite elements this
will simply be the expansion in the
finite element basis. So this is one way
of thinking about it. Now going back to
Shannon and even before to cautilnikov
vitka nquest and so on what we realize
is that this is a very very tight
coupling. there is even a bjection. So
whether you look at the infinite
dimensional space or whether you look at
the finite dimensional space this is
functions on on the on the points on the
grid they are ex one and the same and
there is no aliasing error in this case
the aliasing error is simply you take a
function x. So this is like a encoding
error or autoenccoding error, right? You
take a function, you go down to finite
dimensions, then you go back up to
infinite dimensions and then this this
is tight coupling. There's no there's no
error here. Right? So whether I am
looking at a function or whether I'm
looking at a value of the grid, they're
one and the same provided and this is
the key place where Nquest Swedish
mathematician or scientist his
contribution is vital. So he realized
that the grid has to be dense enough.
Okay. So you cannot just take a very
very sort of sparse grid and say that
the values on the grid will be able to
explain the function entirely. Now who
among you at least sitting in maybe the
people in zoom can also respond. But who
among you knows what will be the density
of the grid given that my frequencies
the highest frequency in the system is
omega. So what would be how many points
do I need at least to represent a
function which has omega frequencies?
Yeah.
>> Uh, this will be the spacing, right? I
want the number of points. So, you're
saying that it should be omega points.
It's between 0 and one. No, but you're
close. Yes.
>> Two *
>> 2 * omega + one. You need a little bit
more than omega. So, this is the nquest
barrier. Okay. So, essentially what it
says is that as long as you have two *
omega + one points because you have
minus omega to omega. So, you have 2 *
omega + 1. and uh then you're this is
fine. This is this famous Shannon
theorem. It's a beautiful if you go to
Wikipedia and read it and you look at
the proof it's anyone can understand it.
It's that simple. And you know the story
is that Shannon he he just stumbled
across it right? He he was a genius. He
stumbled across in 1948 and no one cared
about it. It was too mathematical, too
abstract but it's one of the most cited
papers in the history of mankind or
something. So it's sort of but it's
beautiful. It's really worth having a
look at but for our purposes this
suffices right so it says that there's
an infinite dimensional space there's a
finite dimensional space and they're
completely related to each other through
this channel niquist criteria which is
functions and agreement so now let's try
to keep are there any questions everyone
understands the setting how we go
between infinite and finite dimensions
and not make an error okay so this is a
key point here that we don't make an
error now the question is what happens
Once we have this set up, so we have an
infinite dimensional space, we have
finite dimensions, we know how to go
between them. So let's try to analyze
what our neural operators or what our
neural networks, what operator learning
methods do. Okay, let's start with
CNN's, right? So in this case, we start
with the CNN plus interpolation of
course, right? And this was not
surprising. I think one of you already
observed this in the last lecture that
this will not work that this this can't
be any there will be some aliasing error
and let's see why is that
so there are different arguments that
one can one can use in this setting but
let's take the simplest argument. So
remember that um
Reno is implies
that there is no that there is complete
equivalence between grid resolutions.
You can move between different greater
resolutions. Right? So if you don't have
logically if you don't have this
equivalence between greater resolutions
it cannot be aren. So you can use that
contraositive uh argumentation.
And I think as one of you already
observed last lecture, we can just use
that contraositive argumentation right
here.
So remember what CNN's do right in 1D,
it's the same in 2D or 3D whatever is
that these are discrete convolutions
right everything is discrete. So the the
setting is completely fine. So we take
an input function right we sample it on
a dense enough grid so that the
conditions of the nquis channel theorem
are satisfied 2 omega + 1 and uh then we
have an exact representation. Similarly
for the output when we sample down we
have an exact representation. So
theoretically this uh whether you take
the infinite dimensional object or the
finite dimensional object they are one
and the same right. But now what does a
CNN do? What a CNN does is that it takes
the input. Sorry for the notational uh
mistake here. So K is a kernel and C is
your input function. It could be a band
limited function. So now we learn on a
certain grid and we change the grid.
That's that's the basic idea. So let me
just so I have a signal here.
I have a kernel K, right? So this is my
kernel not KI but just K. This uh for
simplicity I took is supported on three
points. Right? So that it's very very
simple. So when we when we learn we take
this kernel we hit it against the
function at these three points learn the
output and the next one we take the same
kernel hit it against these three points
learn the output keep on sliding the
curve. That's a CNN right? You take a uh
kernel and you keep on sliding it and
you read out the outputs. That's what
you do with the CNN. Now we change the
uh resolution. Let's say we we make it
finer. We can also make it coarser and
it's exactly the same same result. Now
when we make it finer, what happens is
that it's the same function. It's a band
limited function. It's the same
function. Whether I sample it on a on
the current grid or on a fine grid, you
still satisfy an equest, right? Because
you have you have said that on your
given grid on on the grid that you
learned you trained, it's already
satisfying condition. So when you take
more points, of course, it trivially
satisfies the condition. Now you have
these values. They're not the same,
right? Because the values are what they
are. But now you take the same kernel
and let's say that I was centering
around this point. So I take these three
points and uh so let's say I wanted to
center around this. So I I multiply the
kernel. I slide the kernel here. And now
you can see that the kernel has the same
values. But these points are not the
same as these three original points in
orange, right? Because they're slightly
different. They're not the these are
nice functions. They're smooth
functions. So they can't be very very
different but they're not exactly the
same. So when you multiply the kernel
and I think you pointed this out in the
last lecture that you don't resize the
kernel keep the same kernel and you move
it along but with a different set of
points and the moment you do that so you
can imagine that earlier it was giving
it was multiplying with these three
points. Now the same at the same
instantiation it is multiplying with
these three points which are close to
these points in their value but they're
not exactly the same. So of course the
outputs are not going to be the same
right because the outputs are not going
to be the same you're creating an error
when you're moving between these two
grades and because of that it cannot be
a real this error might be small right
because after all these three values are
probably close to these three values
because the functions are close to each
other but they are not one and the same
and because they're not one and the same
you get a small error maybe in the next
layer this error grows in the next layer
it grows further in the next layer it
grows further and then you um things
happen right stuff happens. So this
shows that this is actually highly
resolution dependent and essentially
fixed kernel fixed input. So you have
fixed kernel
you don't change the size of the kernel
and fixed input or not fixed input or
variable input
you don't need that okay so is it clear
that why this cannot be resolution
independent because a function changes
the inputs change but your kernel
remains the same and there is no way for
the function kernel to know that the
function is the same because it just
sees these discrete values. Okay. Then
then things don't work out. Is it clear?
Okay. So that's why you see with the and
we have this numerical examples. We have
seen them before that uh things don't
work out when we take this and as you go
more and more uh in resolution both
super as well as subresolution
you end up with large errors right
there's no generalization. And you can
do this mental exercise with a coarser
grid. Right? Because in a coarser grid
you'll have even less points. I don't
want to crowd it any further. It's
already very crowded but this will be
like three points. You take the same
curve and you hit very different values.
So again there's no way for this to be
resolution independent and consequently
it's not representation independent. So
this this framework that we proposed it
hits this pro problem in an up and says
that hey there's no way that CNN's are
going to generalize across grids. There
is an obvious reason for that. Okay but
what about FNO's right? because CNN's uh
we expected that right so to alleviate
this problem people proposed FNOS's now
what are FNOS's fnos have essentially
two components because this lifting and
projection these are these are point
these are pointwise operations they are
not they don't involve space at all so
there is no no issue whatsoever with
space because this is spatial property
right so when you change spatial
location you can look at different
frequencies they're sort of coupled so
uh there are two things here we have
convolution which is done in 4 year
space and the key point is that it's a
fixed number of modes right this is the
point that I emphasized uh repeatedly in
the last lecture is that when you use
fno you fix the number of uh hidden
modes fy modes and you do the processing
so remember so we have two elements here
convolution in fa space and followed by
a pointwise nonlinearity so take a
convolution then we apply pointwise
nonlinearity and we see what happens
right So this is this is the basic
throughput for FN. But now it turns out
so earlier with uh CNN's the convolution
did not work. So let alone the
nonlinearity. There is no way the
nonlinearity is going to balance out
what the convolution didn't do. But now
let's look at the convolution. The
convolution is much smarter now. It's
not uh is not working in physical space
at all. It's working in FIA space. So
you would expect better better behavior
here. So in particular if my because
it's sort of fa domain so I I assume
that my function space is not just band
limited but even periodic this this
makes sense this this is a good good
function space to start with right so
you have finitely many functions these
are periodic so you can write things in
fa series sine and cosine so essentially
what happens is now this is the picture
it looks very complicated but it isn't
so let us look at it from the infinite
dimensional perspective and let's Let's
go back to the finite dimensional
perspective right in finite dimensions
here this is uh essentially reading out
values in the 4 year series there's no
question so you take a function PK so
there are k capital k frequencies both
negative and positive and then it's very
clear zero is also there that and
everything is complex valued right so
this is fa transform is complex valued
so you have to work with complex valued
in implementation what you do is you
just store the real and the imaginary
components separately. So it's treat it
at two different channels. So this
operator here don't uh don't worry about
what it is. It just takes a function and
read outs reads out its FA coefficients
or FA 4A coefficients and there there
are 2K + one right. So we know that this
is this is the case. Now the FIA
transform what does it do? It simply
reads out the FIA coefficients. So this
is essentially the identity not the
identity map it's the FIA transform. So
it will just read out the FIA
coefficients here and this one is just
um the essentially the discrete FIA
transform. So it will read out the FIA
coefficients here. No issues with that
FIA transform. So this is um it's
respecting all the properties. This is
clearly commuting. But now the key
element of FN O is this FIA multiplier
right? So this is a matrix now. So it's
a matrix which takes uh 2k + 1
components and transforms them into 2 k
prime + 1 components right k prime is
usually much less than k but it need not
be but usually we take k prime which is
fixed and it's less than k is the usual
setting so we take a function which
might have 100 frequencies active
frequencies we project it down maybe 20
frequencies which is the usual thing now
this is the strength because we are
putting it into a finite number of 4
year modes. This is just finite
dimensional operation. This thing is
just identity commutes. Everything is
finite dimensional here. And then when
you take the inverse for your year
transform, you take this k + k prime + 1
coefficients and you go back to the to
the biggest space here. Okay. And again
this is commuting. So essentially if you
one can do the math but it's not not
essential. We can convince ourselves
without doing the detailed calculation
which will take 5 minutes is that
essentially the convolution because it
is done in 4 year space because the
number of 4 year modes is truncated this
is going to work seamlessly right the
convolution is not going to be a problem
here which is good because we want that
the convolution is is going to be uh
areno so within a fa layer the
convolution because it is done in fia
space and because you're cutting off the
number of fia coefficients this is going
to be representation equivalent that's
good because for CNN's the convolution
was not right but what about the
nonlinearity the activation because it's
the key without the nonlinearity this
method is not going to work it will
reduce to a linear method so what is uh
what about the nonlinearity this is
where problems happen and why is that
because nonlinearities
don't work with pointwise nonlinearities
don't work with band limited functions
so remember convolutions are reinos
within this space of periodic b limited
functions because if you take arbitrary
functions who knows what happens but
within this space this is completely
fine but now what happens to
nonlinearities let's let's uh here some
math is necessary a little bit at least
so just imagine that your input function
now so you've done the convolution you
finished the convolution your input
function let me call it as v of x is
nothing but um little k from 1 to
capital k it could be minus also but let
Let me just take the positive
frequencies VK sin K by X something like
this right so periodic function so you
can write down in FIA series and this is
what your function is now you are
applying pointwise nonlinearity to this
function right so sigma of E of X now
let's take sigma to be the simplest who
can tell me what is the simplest
nonlinearity it's a square right so you
take a if you think of a nonlinearity
the simplest nonlinearity is a square
and that's the simple Right. So let us
say this is v ^ 2 evaluated at the point
x. So that would be the sum over k from
1 to capital k of v k sin k pix².
So what happens if I have let's say k is
10. So my biggest term there is sin 10
pix right? And when I take a square what
will happen? What is the largest
frequency that will show up? So you have
sin 10 x². What what what is the value
that we get in terms of signs? 20.
Right? So whenever you take sin of x and
you square it, you get sin square of x.
But that's sin 2x, right? You can
represent this. So this immediately
becomes between k from 1 to 2k of some
whatever a k sin kix. So whenever you
take nonlinearities like a square you
take point-wise functions the frequency
is going to be with the square is going
to be doubled right and if you take a
fourth power it would be multiplied by a
four if you take eth power it will be
multiplied by an 8 and these are all
polomials any nonlinearity can be
approximated by a polomial so all that
will happen is that the power is going
to grow. So if you have 10 frequencies
and you apply nonlinearity to your
function, this is going to increase the
range of frequencies. You'll introduce
high frequencies that were not there
before. Is this point clear? So this is
a very very important point and this is
where things fail that uh if you're
looking at things point-wise, it's very
very different. But when you think in
terms of functions, modes can couple up
and spatial points can be correlated to
each other. So this is a this is an
important point here. So this is where
things break. Okay. So let me show you
with the example here. So f is a
function. I think it is very similar to
what I said. It's just it is sum of 10
signs up to 10 signs. Right? So this is
the orange one. Now what we do is we
apply different nonlinearities. So we
have relu which is uh the the
nonlinearity that is very very useful.
Ku is some approximation of relu right?
So a smoother approximation of ReLU.
ReLU is just a positive part. So it
takes the orange and it produces the
blue one. Right? So just takes cuts off
the negative parts of the function. So
you would think fine in physical space
it looks exactly very nice. Right? You
just take a function you cut out its
negative parts. But in FIA space things
are very different. So this is the
orange function. In FIA space as I said
it's between I can't read it carefully.
I think it's between minus 20 and 20. So
there are 20 frequencies now. Right? And
the nquest barrier is uh telling you
what the maximum frequency is. The
nquest frequency is telling you what the
maximum frequency is. I take the the so
the function as you can see it has no
frequencies band limited. So it has no
frequencies beyond minus 20 and 20. But
the moment you take uh relu the blue one
I don't know how well you see it because
these numbers are going to be small. uh
the high frequencies are usually small
but you can see that the frequencies
they creep out on both sides and they go
not just 40 because now this relu is not
square if it would have been square it
would have stopped at 40 but relu is
some if you want to approximate it with
polinomials it's very very badly posed
so you can even see that this is what 60
80 whatever there are some small
frequencies these are small these are
not so small right these are fairly
large frequencies so this tells us that
even if your convolution was keeping the
mathematical structure was
representation equivalent as soon as you
apply nonlinearities happens and in
other words what happens is that uh
things break down you break the band
limits. So the spaces within which you
showed representation equivalence they
are not act activated anymore. These
high frequencies are spous right they do
not exist because your functions are
band limited. So there should be no way
that they should be there in your uh
ground truth. They are introduced
specifically by this uh by this action
of these pointwise nonlinearities and
because of that they create problems. We
will see that we'll see that in a
second. But this is absolutely essential
to what we are going to discuss after
the break. So if there are any questions
now is the time to ask it. Did you
understand this entire construction? Why
nonlinear? Yes, go ahead. But then at
the next layer we should truncate the
frequency.
>> We could truncate it but then we again
reintroduce it. Right? So now remember
that the frequencies are it's a very
very good good observation that you have
this high frequency information. There
is some correcting mechanism by which uh
that so you create these high
frequencies then you are trying to
compress it down. So you have to somehow
unlearn the error then you again make
the error. You're trying to unlearn the
error. You're g make the error. There is
a compensatory mechanism but it's not
exact. So the error is going to be there
and it can grow means in the next round
the the nonlinearity can alleviate it
even further. Then you try to truncate.
So there is a mechanism but it's not
enough right because you always have
nonlinearities in the next round. So you
cannot sort of remain within the within
the frequency space. You'll make errors.
So you see that right? So you saw that
already with this example that I showed
you in the last lecture.
It's a it's an artificial example but
it's done on purpose to be an artificial
example. So now here so you you take a
function with I don't know 60 on a 64
squared grid or something like that. So
here there is no nquest uh the nquis
barrier is broken. When you sample under
the nucleus barrier, you can anyway you
can't expect any reasonable
approximation, right? Because the
discrete values no longer represent the
continuous function. This so you don't
expect anything. But over the nuisance
barrier you expect that but you don't
get that right because what happens is
that as soon as you change the grid
resolution ever so slightly the errors
which are there due to the high
frequency components these are large now
because high frequency components are
not damped in a PD usually the high
frequency components are damped
otherwise it will be white noise and
then you get these large errors okay so
this sort of explains what's
going on quite well and even you do see
them in the in the in the in the
practical examples right so now here the
the input functions are indeed band
limited the output is not band limited
because it's a solution of a PTE but
nevertheless the you can truncate it so
the high bands are very very small but
nevertheless what happens is that
whenever you do this for a for a CNN
they say unit but it's it's the same
effect you have this behavior because
neither the convolution nor the
nonlinearity are uh are going to work
right for FN O as you rightly pointed
out uh the convolution can fight against
what the nonlinearity is doing so you
have better behavior but as you can see
it's not exact right so there is some
error here and in this regime it is
really bad because now the high
frequencies that are because now this is
on a smaller grade so you don't have any
truncation effects and you get very very
bad results so this shows you that these
methods at least they're not going to
generalize mathematically across culture
solutions. They could have uh better
empirical performance but they're not
going to generalize right. So this is
still an issue. So now the challenge of
course is that so far we have shown we
have created a framework that can
understand or formalize how things
generalize across grid resolutions. Now
this is simply because we're dealing
with functions right if you're dealing
with discrete vectors we don't have
these considerations. There's exactly
one input and one output. Who cares
about anything else? But when you're
dealing with functions, you have these
multiple inputs outputs and you have to
think carefully. But so we have shown
that some things are not representation
equivalent. But we have not really
designed uh a representation equivalent
neural operator. This is what we will do
after the break. you know exactly what
we're going to do because on Monday I
think bogdan he taught you convolutional
operators which is precisely the thing
that does does generalize across grids
right so this has been designed to do so
but let's uh take a break here I suggest
that we meet at 5 we so that we can we
can finish the whole of convolution
neural operator okay so let's let's take
a break uh if you have any questions you
can always ask me during the break or
ask on the chat box okay So now we want
to design arena right? So this would be
our objective. How are we going to do
this? Okay. So we will use convolutions
again means uh in the next lecture we
will look at other alternatives but
convolutions are a very very powerful
powerful answer on very very powerful
way to do things. So we keep on doing
convolutions but this time with a twist
right so essentially
I'm a big Star Wars fan so that's why
it's convolutions strike back. Okay. So
what is the so the the the paper itself
was it's called convolutional operator.
It's it was proposed um a few years ago
and I think you were introduced to it in
the tutorial. If you didn't go to the
tutorial just follow the recording. It's
it's quite quite useful. So again we are
going to work with convolutions but this
time it would be in physical space right
not not not in 4 space. So the idea is
fairly simple. So we have exactly the
same sort of setting band limited
functions right and we we assume that
the operator is between band limited
functions. We assume that the bands can
be very very large right. So this this
is this is this is possible and you have
enough density uh in your points to be
able to resolve the bands. This is these
are the main assumptions right. So it's
an operator between band limited
functions and its main building blocks
are these projection and lifting
operators. These are very very standard.
So you so remember that both so in
essentially lifting operator P is just
effective coordinates.
It's like given a physical system your
inputs are let's say temperature but
maybe the model decides that it's not
just temperature that describes the
system. It could be the pressure it
could be the I don't know a relative
temperature a potential temperature
entropy or whatever some physical
variables. We do this in physics all the
time. Here we don't a priority prescribe
what this effective coordinates are
going to be but let the system learn it
right so this is this is the basic idea
and the projection or the operator that
goes down is just its inverse so these
are pointwise so at each point in space
they act so there is no issue with the
representation equivalence it doesn't
really matter right and remember because
we're band limited functions we can
always sample them in a grid and it's
it's exactly the same so the key is
again convolution and nonlinearity so So
let's start with convolution. So as you
can see it has this encoder decoder
structure with convolutions and
nonlinearities. This I will I will
explain this diagrams much better. So we
start with uh convolutions and here
instead of just using discrete
convolutions because we are with band
limited functions we can use continuous
convolutions but on band limited
functions. So what is a continuous
convolution? As you can imagine given an
input V the output is going to be this
is a function right band limited
function it belongs to how did I call
band BW so BW so these are your band
limited functions with the maximum band
or is it W or omega I can't see but
let's say omega so the output is simply
given by some V hat is not a okay then
that would be the FIA transform which is
which is not Nice. So v tilda which is
given by x of x is equal to the integral
over your domain of k of x - y uh is the
convolution kernel. k omega it says k
omega of x - y v of y dy. So it's a
continuous convolution right? So we have
to see how this continuous convolution
is done. But in principle it's a
continuous convolution. But the kernel
is going to be discrete. So what does
that mean? So the kernel is going to be
discrete which means that this k omega
of x for instance is a sum of some ci
um delta
x - x i or something like that. So it's
at a discrete set of points k from 1 to
i to i something like this. Okay. So
it's still discrete in the sense that
it's so this is essentially a delta
distribution which means that this guy
is going to be evaluated at a discrete
set of points but we think of the input
itself as being continuous even though
the kernel itself is going to be
discrete and this is mathematically
completely equivalent. So in a sense
nothing nothing fancy is being done
here. It is still a sum. So you're still
sliding the convolution window but
you're doing it over the band limited
functions. And I argue that and I'm
going to show to you that this is
actually going to be a reeno. The
convolution is going to be a reno just
because I change perspectives. I do
continuous convolutions and band limited
functions. I I'll do that in a second.
But this is sort of the commuting
diagram that you can always go between
these two guys by sampling and go up by
the sync interpolation. So let me try to
explain why this changes perspective,
right? Because it seems magical that
just by doing this you change things. So
let's add a blank page and write down
what we are doing. So we need we need to
draw some pictures now right. So you
have uh let's say this is we need two
grids are enough because you can argue
with the third grid yourself.
Okay. So this is your
original grid. Let me use a few
something like this. So this is my input
grid. This is my
these are supposed to be uniformly
distributed points but I'm never good at
drawing. So okay so let's say that this
is between 01 this is between 01
and uh now this is going to be your
training resolution
training resolution and this will be
your test resolution. They seem to be
the same but I'm going to add some more
points.
Okay. So now let's take some input and
output relationship
like this is exactly the same function
and you can imagine that you have the
same similar sort of functions at the
output. Right? Now you have a discrete
kernel right so you have a discrete
kernel because it's still so this is a
band limited function. The orange one is
a band limited function because that's
our input output and we have a discrete
kernel. I need a different color
probably for this
magenda. So that is a discrete kernel.
Let's say it's just three points like
before. And what we're going to do is
that we're going to take this kernel and
during training we're going to slide it
over. Right? So for instance at this
point we're going to slide the kernel
as before. Nothing nothing fancy is
being done. So we have these three
points and these are going to hit these
three points right. So they multiply and
they keep on sliding. So this is what we
have done. So even though my functions
are continuous because the kernel is
discrete I can write it as a essentially
as a sum as a reman sum. Now what do I
do and then I get some values right? So
this is I get some values. Now what
happens when I test on a different
resolution? So now the nquest barrier is
satisfied. So in principle this band
limited function is approximated is
exactly is exactly represented on this
grid as well as on this grid. This is my
assumption right. But now remember it's
a continuous convolution. It's a
continuous uh function that I'm going to
evaluate. So now my input has been given
on all these points.
Actually it would be nice to go back to
my original
picture. Right? So because we yeah where
is the double grid this one so remember
this is exactly in this setup now so we
already have some operator here which
tells us that uh so this is my trained
operator right and now I'm going to test
it on a different operator so I have to
essentially use this kind of a formula
if I have this tight coupling for band
limited functions I have this tight
coupling so what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to test it on this uh new
resolution And remember so the function
on this new points is band limited. So
given these point values these new point
values I can always lift them to an
infinite dimensional function. How will
I do that? This will be the sync
interpolation.
Okay. And then once I have the sync
interpolation I have this infinite
dimensional function. I can downsample
it again by pointwise sampling. So I
have a third grid. This can be of any
resolution. Right?
So, but I will choose my training
resolution. So, back to training
resolution.
And this is very subtle. That's why I
want you to pay attention. So, now 1 2 3
4 5 right. So, this back to the training
resolution and I have the same input
something like this. So, what did I do
here? I started out with a input on a
tensor grid. I said that these are band
limited functions. So I I know how to go
back to the infinite dimension get back
the function. This is my sync
interpolation. Then using the sync
interpolent which is exact I'm going to
down sample it back to my original or
training resolution. So I get these
values and now you can you can see that
these values are exactly going to be the
same as these values because it's back
on original grid. So I have resized my
input right? So I've not resized my
kernel. My kernel is exactly as before.
But because I'm dealing with band
limited functions, they have exactly the
same values. So this guy is going to be
exactly the same as this guy. So when I
slide my kernel now doesn't matter to
me, right? So I slide my kernel. So
earlier for a CNN, what I was doing is
that my kernel would have just hit these
three values and given you a wrong wrong
output, right? But now I'm not saying
that I'm going to hit my kernel on that.
I'm going to resize my input and I'm
going to hit these three values
which is precisely what we had before
right so back to so the this this entire
thing commutes it's exactly the same
value so we are fixing the kernel so
fixed kernel as before nothing changes
but we are resizing the input and output
resizing input
and this is the trick of using
convolution continuous inverse
convolutions and band limited functions.
So the what in implementation what you
do and this is what I think Bogdan must
have explained I I didn't look at the
recording but I'm sure he has explained
this what you do is that you given an
input you resize it back to the training
resolution and you evolve and you can do
this because it's exactly the same
function you have this guarantee because
things are band limited so it's not
magical it just follows from how I do my
convolution because when I do continuous
convolutions I can do whatever I I have
to interpret these continuous functions
in some discrete space and the
particular discrete space that I I want
to interpret them is so I'll always take
my input I'll do the sync interpolent in
practice this is a sort of modified sync
interpolent and then I will apply my
convolution on this and each time I
change resolution I can do that okay so
this is a subtle point but it's an
important point that makes this work now
if I had a sparer grid if I had a
coarser grid now this becomes very very
dense let's say that I had a coarser
grid Right? So just 1 2 three points.
What do I do? And I'm assuming that the
nquest condition is satisfied. That the
function is being resolved by these
three points. I take the sync function,
right? Go to the infinite dimensional
space and then project it back to this
original training resolution. Put my
convolution there. I have exactly the
same function because uh they they're
representing the same same values. So
doing this is allowing me of course if I
break the nquis resolution the nquis
barrier then all bets are off because
then of course these these are not
representing it right so it's just a
different it's a very very subtle
difference it's a minor difference but
it's an important difference in how you
apply these uh discrete operators and
where you apply these discrete
operators. So the idea is to resize the
grids. That's why it becomes very
complicated when you try to do it on a
complex geometry. It becomes a bit
harder. But on a regular grid, it's
rather straightforward. And this is why
despite having a discrete convolution
kernel by using it in a in this
continuous manner on band limited
functions, we are ensuring that the
convolution is going to be arena. I said
it's a subtle point. So think about it
and when you implement it, you can try
different inputs and see that it
actually works. Anyway, so this was uh
the point. I'm happy to take any
questions if there are some immediate
questions or I let you mull over because
as I said this is a subtle point. If you
don't understand something, please come
back to me at the end of today's lecture
or in the next lecture and I'll try to
explain it again. Okay. So the way you
should think of it is what does it mean
to do something continuously? Then once
I do it continuously I can do it on any
grid as long as the representation is
there as long as there is no error that
I'm making and because if I do not have
band limited functions this will not
work right because then you will have
high frequencies that will corrode your
uh approximation okay yes
>> is it then more useful to like the data
to train on higher resolution will give
you better results or
>> depends on what your here this is
something that we have sort of put as a
post-processing a pre-processing step
right so you have the choice so in
practice of course uh you do something
different but since you asked I will
tell you what you what you should do in
practice it's a very s maybe we maybe
I'll ask them to cover this in a
tutorial because uh you don't know a
priority you have been given some
resolutions you know sometimes it is not
a fixed resolution it's often a mixture
of resolutions you can choose what
resolution to train Right? It need not
be the coarsest resolution. It need not
be the finest resolution. It could be
something in between. But this framework
allows you to do that. It doesn't mean
that the finest resolution is always the
best because uh it might be
computationally more difficult because
remember that the kernel size might be
the same but it has to do more
operations, right? So it might not be
the best choice. It depends on the
compute, depends on the problem in hand.
But you in principle if you look at this
picture that you see up on your screen
you can train at any resolution even at
a mixture of resolutions right because
uh how do you do at a mixture of
resolutions again you take you don't
resize your kernel your kernel is still
fixed right you take the data at a given
resolution use this interpolation right
to go to a fixed resolution train there
and then test at different resolutions
but it's not necessary that you train at
the highest possible in fact sometimes
It's not affordable. There is no model
at the moment which can for instance do
a billion points is computationally
unfeasible.
Shenang one of the TAs in the course he
says that he can do it but let's see
whether by the end of the course whether
he can do it or not right but it's it's
quite a challenge. Okay, good. So this
is a very subtle point. I want all of
you to think about it to understand it
and if you have any questions come back
to me. But this is just one element,
right? It shows that the convolution is
going to be representation or resolution
independent. It does not tell you and by
the way in the paper there is a rigorous
mathematical proof but uh intuitively
this is what is happening and this is
more important now but uh so this was
the contrast with CNN's right fixed
kernel resized input CNN's fixed kernel
fixed input and this is why it was
failing right so this was sort of the
main main difference subtle difference
but a key difference but remember that
FNO the convolution was already doing
this right so by doing it in 4 space I
was already ensuring that the convolute
because there what I was doing is here
I'm resizing in physical space there I
was resizing in 4 year space I took
putting it back to the fixed 4 year
space that's why it was working but the
key was the nonlinearity the
nonlinearity was what was not working so
let me spend a bit of time to explain
how we can make the nonlinearity work
and this is quite quite interesting it's
uh so it it it requires some some
explanation and pictures are worth a
thousand words right so let's try to
explain it through the pictures. So
remember what happened in non with
nonlinearities we're dealing with band
limited functions. So if you take sin 10
x take it square you get sin 20x you
introduce high frequencies. So this was
the picture that we had that in fia
space we have introduced uh high
frequencies right and then so the key
trick now is to allow for this to
happen. We know that we need
nonlinearities because without
nonlinearity there's no universal
approximation and without universal
approximation it's useless. So we need
to put in nonlinearities but we can be
clever about how we put our
nonlinearities right and the idea is uh
simple and so elegant.
So what we do is the following in in
this construction. So we realize that if
I take a square essentially I double the
bandwidth. If I take a fourth power, I
quadruple the bandwidth and so on. So
with any polomial I I have a complete
control of how much of the bandwidth I'm
going to increase. So let's for
simplicity just focus on the square.
Right? So this is the simplest maybe I
introduce um new page so that I
introduce a new page so that I can
explain it better.
That's probably neither here nor there.
Let me try to because for me to draw
these functions would be rather honorous
right so I don't want to do that but uh
so remember that if there's a square you
double the bandwidth right so now and
then this is what the nonlinearity does
what if I allow my nonlinearity or my
activation to give me space to do that
so what do I mean by that I take a
function which is has 10 frequencies I
know what frequencies it has because I'm
dealing with band limited functions I
know my bands Right? Then I say that
instead of just applying a nonlinearity
pointwise, I artificially
put it on a denser grid or I
artificially allow it for allow higher
frequencies. Let's say double the
frequencies. How can I do that? This
operation is what is called an
upsampling operation. So what upsampling
does is that you take a function and you
put more resolution into it. You
upsample it, right? So you you put it on
a denser grid. Uh you can do that. So
essentially what you do is that you take
a band limited function which is 10
bands or 10 frequencies and you put it
in 20 frequencies. I'm just just saying
something very rough, right? How will I
do that? It still has 10 frequencies,
but I say that my function is has 20
frequencies means I sample it on more
points, right? So that the nquis barrier
is satisfied. And these artificially
high frequencies that I'm introducing, I
just put them to zero. So I have a
function which is which is between which
has 20 frequencies, but from the 11th to
the 20th frequency, the value is zero.
So completely fine. It's a construction
which is there. I of course have more
points right I have more bandwidth now
so I take more points then I apply my
nonlinearity okay so remember that this
function is uh sampled at more points 40
points now instead of uh 20 points by
artificially putting in this zero
frequencies and then doing the sync
interpolation then I apply the
nonlinearity my actual function still
has 10 frequencies right so it will
simply go into a function to 20
frequencies which I can sample on this
discrete set of points because I have
enough points to sample this. So the
output is something that I can sample.
So this is where I apply the nonlinear I
I'll explain it in formulas later but
I'm just trying to give you an intuitive
picture. So I have this um extra let's
say bandwidth. I have increased my
bandwidth. Literally I have increased my
bandwidth here and I have more
frequencies. I have more points to
densely sample the function. So I can
represent it correctly. And then of
course I want to go back to my original
space. But I know that if I have 40
frequencies I can go or 20 frequencies I
can go back simply by doing the same
sort of interpolation. Right? So this is
the trick that you allow your
architecture your activation function to
be able to adjust to the fact that your
bandwidth is going to increase by
increasing the sampling or by increasing
the frequencies and so on. So let me try
to explain what goes on here in terms of
formulas. I still want to go from band
limited functions with 10 frequencies to
band limited functions with 10
frequencies. Right? But to do so I will
use first an upsampling. Of course now
this doesn't work. I'll do an
upsampling. Let me use my favorite
color. So, use an upsampling here. So,
somehow I have to take my function which
is 10 frequencies and embedded in a
space of functions with 20 frequencies
simply by setting my frequencies to be
zero, higher frequencies to be zero.
Right? So, this is what this upsampling
does. But it is uh now sampled on a
denser grid so that uh maybe your
original grid is already dense enough
for the nquiser to be uh otherwise you
have to do that. Then I apply my
nonlinearity still takes 10 frequencies
and puts it into 20 because my function
originally has 20 frequencies. So now
this is in the right space right because
no space has been violated. It's within
the limits that we set for it. And then
we have to go back down to my original
bandwidth and this is where down
sampling or subsampling works. So what
do I do? I have my function which are on
all these points. I write in sync
interpolent and come back to the smaller
set of points. Right? So this is
essentially what what is going on here.
I think the algorithmic realization is a
little bit more delicate because these
integrals are difficult to evaluate and
I think bogdan already explained the
modified sync filters that you have to
use. So you start upsample this is
essentially an artificial a third
operation because nothing nothing new is
happening then you apply the
nonlinearity whatever be the
nonlinearity this is independent of the
nonlinearity I'm just using square
because then we know exactly what the
upper upper bound limit is going to be
and down sample with your filter right
so if I do this then the interesting
thing is that this phenomena that we saw
before that of course square you can do
exactly by doubling the bandwidth but
for blue you you still get much better
sort of uh so look at what is happening
here.
So now my my after this procedure so I I
do this upsampling and then down
sampling. What happens is that you kill
these frequencies. These frequencies are
adjusted for right. So these frequencies
are adjusted for and now these tiny tiny
little frequencies are still there
because of course by doubling the band
I'm not going to get rid of all the
things that ReLU introduces. But for
polomials this is exact. So that's what
we have said that this is as long as
this is much larger the upsampling band
is much larger than your original band
then we can mathematically show that
this entire operation works and you
allow for this increased bandwidth. Of
course in practice you cannot go from 10
frequencies to 10,000 frequencies.
Right? Um so you you make an
approximation and in fact it seems that
doubling is always the best empirically
but theoretically we can show it for
polinomials we can show it for rational
functions rational nonlinearities that
this can be made exact but in practice
this is still there is a very very high
frequency content that we have to live
with. So what did we do here? So if you
think in terms of computing diagrams so
we took the this guy we embedded it into
high frequency even though my original
function this is just sort of identity
right so I did not really do anything
here this is completely uh this diagram
commutes no issue with that I apply my
nonlinearity my nonlinearity goes
between these two bandwidths no problems
so this is also commuting and
downsampling also commutes because I can
always go back right so this is a very
subtle point and this is the essence of
this architecture that you make your
nonlinearities
uh such that you adjust to this
increasing bandwidth. So if you want to
think of it intuitively, we are allowing
for something to happen that we know is
going to happen and because of that we
can temper its consequences, right? And
the interesting thing here is that this
entire so remember earlier my non
nonlinearity was a local operation at
each point I was applying a loop but now
I'm not doing that right because I'm
taking this uh upsampling and it's down
sampling operators. These are non-local
operators because I'm multiplying with a
filter and cutting them off and so on.
So this entire activation is actually
non-local.
This is very interesting, right? Because
we have a non-local activation. Earlier
it was a local activation and by taking
this non-local activation, we are able
to sort of adjust for this aliasing
error that is bound to happen when I
apply a nonlinearity to a pointwise
function. Okay, so this is sort of the
the key element here. Are there any
questions? Again, very subtle points,
but now the constructions become more
elaborate, right? Questions? No. Yeah.
Go ahead.
like this
shadow doesn't hold for it. No, it it
does hold for the because of my original
assumption is that uh okay now now I I
get I I get your question right. So now
I allow for my but remember that I have
sort of introduced this artificial so
because my space is now no longer
limited to the original bandwidth right
it is a higher bandwidth but from a
higher bandwidth I can always go down to
a lower bandwidth simply by downsampling
by coarsening my operator right so this
is not a this is still an identity it's
uh the the number of points is still the
points of this increased bandwidth right
and then they are down sampled onto to
the original bandwidth. So I don't see
why the maybe we can talk about it and I
can explain it to you why this happens.
Okay. So this is a very subtle point
that one has to one has to explain but I
have to admit that if you take relu
essentially the bandwidth is infinite.
So I have to do some truncation and
there will be a slight error but we
never take relu we take some smoother
nonlinearities. There's something called
swish which is essentially a fourth
power. So we can quadruple it and so on.
Okay. So let me now I have to I have to
show a little bit more uh what do how do
we do this in practice right in
practice. So the ingredients are just
this convolution and this nonlinearity
this non-local nonlinearity right but in
uh in practice we have to put them
together and this is where more
elaborate architectures or more
elaborate uh methods algorithms are
really necessary. Okay. So this is
essentially what is called a unit. Um
it's very very common in image
processing in computer vision and what
we do is that we have an operator unit
because a basic unit will just have the
same convolution and the same
nonlinearity that is there in a CNN and
it's not going to be resolution
invariant. So remember that each layer
is uh alias free. So when you couple
them everything remains alias free. So
this is the basic construction. So what
here the name of the game is that it
allows for multiscale information
processing. Okay. So you take uh
information at different scales because
in a physical signal just imagine the
time series of temperature outside you
have some daily variations you have some
seasonal variations you have some hourly
variations and so on. So the multiple
scales are coupled and the idea is to
put all these information somehow
inbuilt uh put some inductive biases
into the architecture to do that. So how
do we do this means as I said we put in
these elementary things. So we always
have the basic nonlinearity and
convolution. Nonlinearity convolution
this is this is going to be very very
standard right. So this is what we call
as a invariant block here means it goes
from the same resolution and maps onto
the same resolution even though within
the resolution we are changing because
we're using the non-local activation and
so on. So you know the activation is
always done in a non-local manner. Okay.
So this is the invariant block. So you
start with a projection. So you learn
the effective coordinates. Then you do
an invariant block. You could have just
staggered onto this and this would be a
standard CNN. But we don't do that. Then
what we do is we keep some component of
it. But the next one we down sample. So
we say that we start with a signal and
this guy is only learning the high
frequencies. The next frequencies are
learned uh in the Ushaped unit. So this
is down sampling. What does it mean?
Apply convolution, apply nonlinearity
and then do a down sampling with this
sync filter that I just described to
you.
And you repeat this process here. So you
learn the courses scales and the courses
scales. This is what is called the
bottleneck. Okay. So signals are now
broken down into different components or
different frequencies. Each of these
frequencies is learned, right? But they
have to be combined back. So the
combination is through these operations
here and as you can see they require
upsampling. So this guy is an upsampling
or a u block because you go back. So
let's say you start with 100 128 x 128
you go down to 64x 64 32x 32 16 x 16 and
you stop at 16 x 16. Then from 16 x 16
you climb up to 32x 32 64x 64 128 128.
But within each resolution you're using
what are called restn nets. Okay,
restnets are skip connections. We have
already seen that before. So you start
with a layer, you use a convolution and
nonlinearity, but you keep the skip
connection maybe a learnable matrix here
and you get a restn net like this. So
you have restnets here, rest nets here
and then you combine them. So then
there's some concatenation. So whatever
you have learned and then this goes up,
right? So this is a bit of a detail.
This has been done in computer vision
quite a lot. We don't change that. We
use the same unit architecture as
before. All that we change is that
within the unit the convolution and the
nonlinearities. This is what we are
modulating. Right? So we are changing to
continuous convolutions and we're using
this alias free non-local
nonlinearities. But this is uh very very
important because if you just had this
the performance won't be there because
the architecture won't be expressive
enough. So by doing this kind of a
U-shaped structure U right what we do is
that we enforce some multiscale
information processing which is uh which
is absolutely essential in this business
to be able to understand different
scales at which the signal propagates
and again the details of this were there
in the tutorial and when you work with
the code you see for yourself how many
layers we need how much of upsampling
and downsampling we need and so on and
you can think of this as some encoder
and this as a decoder for instance
Okay. So what are the properties of
this? Let me hurry up so that I show you
some actual results. So by construction
because we have taken this upsampling
and down sampling in a nonlinearity
because we have taken continuous
convolutions. I have already convinced
you hopefully that this by construction
is areno. And then we can also prove a
universal approximation theorem just
like we did for fno. We need continuous
operators. The spaces are not important
here. So we showed it for soap spaces
but some other people have shown it for
holder continuous functions. This is
this is not important. The key point is
that whenever you are in these kind of
spaces function spaces your fia
coefficients are not bounded right there
in physics you don't have band limited
functions. Essentially your function is
in all possible bands but because it's
physical the higher bands the decay for
instance if it's very very smooth they
decay exponentially otherwise they decay
in a power law basis. So what you can do
is that you can truncate the expansion
and this is how FIA methods work
otherwise they wouldn't work. So we are
upfront saying that we make a little
error and this error can be made as
small as possible by taking something
with infinite bandwidth and projecting
it down to finite bandwidths because
without finite bandwidths we are not
going to
we will introduce additional errors. So
up front we pay the price of a
discretization error right so the
discretization error is this guy here
that we we go from uh essentially a band
limited function to another band limited
function. these bands can be very very
large right and once we do that then
it's essentially finite dimensional
universal approximation theorem for
neural networks so this can be done the
code is already provided to you guys and
you can you can play with the code in
the tutorial so it has all the nice
properties uh but now the crucial sort
of test is what happens when I change
resolution so this is an example of what
happens so remember this is this uh
random assignment problem and now here
you cannot expect anything because the
nquis barrier is broken. Right? So here
even the discrete representation does
not uh preserve the continuous function
itself. But here is where we can when we
upsample is where we can expect
something and as you can see CNO it
provides a flat line because it takes
this uh very very rough functions but it
uh resizes them back to the target grid
learns it and then you can see that
there is no error right so this is this
is what it has been designed for what
about the more practical example and
here things are very interesting so now
you see some examples right so remember
so this is my ground truth truth. This
is the solution of the Navia Stokes
equation. We have been looking at it
repeatedly again and again and again. So
this is the U. So this is the ux UI the
two velocities at time t= 1. Okay. So
you start with t equal to0 the initial
conditions this one and you predict the
solution at t= 1. So that's the basic uh
basic prediction. Now let us look at so
there are some more older architectures
like deep net. they completely fail on
this problem because they only learn
somehow the mean value of the flow. the
CNN and FNO the the two that we have
tested before as I said they do a
reasonable job
but you can see for the CNN that there
is a lot of artifacts here and this is
because of this high frequency
information that gets uh projected onto
here for FNO is quite interesting you
don't have this high frequency but you
still have some artifacts here so this
guy here and this guy here and this
we'll see in the next uh slide is a
consequence of the fact that this
nonlinearity is introducing high
frequencies you're not able to rid of it
and CNO is is doing a very good job as
as expected. So on the on the fixed grid
so this is at 64 squared both training
and rest resolution you see that it's
it's better but this is need not
necessarily be the case it could also be
worse right but in this particular case
it is better even better than the unit
which is its base architecture because
it's really unit with this modified or
modulated activations and nonlinearities
fo has a higher error and this is
primarily because of these patches that
are seen in this data there right and
then what happens is the key test is
what happens when we do this resolution
uh um or test them on different
resolutions and as you can see so we
compare with a unit uh unit is as a CNN
as so you don't resize anything you
don't resize the input you don't resize
the kernel so of course you expect this
kind of a behavior fn we have seen
before the nonlinearity is the one that
has really caused this amplification of
error and CN know it does a very good
job. This is designed to be like that.
But of course once the nquest barrier is
uh being hit uh you can imagine that now
there's not enough bandwidth to even
represent anything. There's a slight
increase in the error. And if you take
the spectrogram the spectrogram is where
the where the spectra is just a FIA
transform right the FIA transform the
ground truth has this behavior. It is
it's decaying. Uh if you see this is a
log scale. So the these guys here are
very very small values 10us 7. So tiny
tiny values but they're not zero as you
can see. Uh and then what does what do
different architectures do? Of course
these are approximations. They're not
going to be exact. Right? So what does
CNO do? It it it learns these
frequencies. It has very low frequencies
here, very low frequencies here. But as
you can see it's only one which is
getting this very very low frequencies.
So it does not have high bandwidth. Of
course, here it doesn't do such a such a
good job. It still has some nonzero
frequencies here. That's not aliasing,
but it's it does didn't learn it. What
about fno and unit? They're much higher
frequencies. You can see that they are
in this range, right? They never they
always have higher frequencies and they
completely get this regions wrong. So
this region there is it is very high
frequency where it should be low and
this guy has similar behavior just
higher values. Right? So this shows
already from the spectrogram because you
don't expect the ground truth as zero
frequencies. You expect that it has
non-trivial frequency behavior that
there is a difference between these
methods and by modifying these
frequencies we're able to first of all
get better results on a fixed grid and
we get able to get this seamless
generalization across grids. So this is
this is what is important. So let me
give you another example which sort of
tells this story in a much more crisp
manner. Okay, there there is more here.
So, let me let me just explain. So, of
course, uh this is all in distribution
and maybe it's time to do a little bit
of in distribution and out of
distribution thing. What's going on?
Yeah. So, what do you mean by in and out
of distribution? Right. So, remember
that uh I have Navia Stokes.
It's very important to learn this now.
So here Stokes
my operator takes uh u0 and produce this
is g the operator and produces uh u at t
equal to 1. Right? Now what is the
distribution? So my u0 is uh some u f
plus summation of some a k u0 k of x. I
don't have to write a x.
So my reference let me explain what this
is. So this is this input that I have
but there is some reference state here
and I have perturbed this reference
state and this has given me this a k. So
this k is from 1 to capital k. I think
it was 24
and this a k is uniformly distributed in
minus11 something like this. So this is
my distribution right? It's a infinite
dimensional distribution but I realize
it with finitely many parameters in this
case 24 parameters. So now in
distribution
so this is uh in distribution means
that uh your any so your test input
v 0 has exactly the same shape means
you're just drawing different random
numbers ak and you're distributing here
but this is it it learns the in
distribution quite well as you can see
in this particular case this is the
input this is the output put CN O FN O
unit right they all are doing a
reasonable job fn for instance does not
get this region right uh unit does a
better job but I think it also doesn't
it makes this more flat for instance
right but these are some minor
differences but now what is out of
distribution so in distribution the
errors as as you said around 3% which is
what it is at this resolution right out
of distribution so here also you see you
saw out of distribution but This was
with respect to the grid inputs, right?
But here out of distribution is I start
with a different different test
distribution not totally unrelated
because that wouldn't simply work right
because uh you learn what you learn and
the rest uh you have to infer. So what I
did in this case is that your K is now
32. So you take much higher frequencies
than are there and I think your AK I'm
not not 100% convinced of this but maybe
AK is between minus A and A no minus B
and B where B is not equal to one it's
greater than one something like this so
you have higher amplitudes and you have
more frequencies so this is not exactly
the same right this the behavior of the
flow is going to change and it is out of
distribution the question is has enough
physics been learned
to be able to represent this and this is
what is sometimes called as we we are
going to focus on this topic quite a bit
later but this is also sometimes called
as zeros short learning in the sense
that you learn on a given distribution
you test on a related yet not identical
distribution and this is very very
important because otherwise what is
machine learning right means you need to
learn something so you can see that
right that you can see that this is
maybe we shifted the origin a little I
don't remember the exact details here
not that they're important you can look
it in the paper you can see that this is
slightly different the flow changes
quite a bit right so the flow changes
quite a bit and in particular these
features of the flow a CNO doesn't do a
bad job it's able to learn that there
are two vortices here it produces them
it gets the right curvature here for
instance and also more or less the right
behavior here it's not exact but look at
fn for instance right it did not even
understand that there are two vortices
it just plucked out this vortex here it
did not get this feature at all and he
did not get the curvature and unit it
also produces a single vortex but in
some random place. It looks very
similar. This feature is not produced
correctly. Neither is the curvature
here. Right? So of course they did not
generalize as well. They did some job
and you can see that so all the three
architectures
did generalize somewhat right but they
did not do it's like the unit it
increased by a factor of three uh FNO
more than a factor of three and CNO more
or less a factor of two so there still
mean 10% is what I would say is
acceptable so in this particular case it
did generalize much better and in in
fact we have done a lot of testing on
this that it does generalize fairly
Not not dramatically but it does
generalize fairly better and the main
advantage is now you know you can argue
that here you had seen the training data
you have never seen the test data it
took one/10enth of a second because we
have very very fast spectral solver but
the CNO takes 1 10,000th of a second so
you still benefit something with
acceptable errors so sometimes it's good
to test your architecture your models
out of distribution but they cannot be
dramatically out of distribution because
then you'll not be able to learn but
they we we will tackle that later but a
little bit out of distribution is not
not a bad idea okay so then let me just
uh continue this is also an important
point that success is actually not a
point value because this was just the
because remember we have a test set
right I don't know how many let's say
128 samples are in the test set but this
is just the mean behavior of the test
set or the median behavior what happens
across the test set is there could be
outliers right and And you see that both
the in distribution and out of
distribution errors for the three
architectures. Let's focus on CNO and
FNO.
So you see that most of them this is the
mean. So this is around three, right?
But even the outliers are not so bad.
It's around four 4%, for FNO it's more
like 6%. So even though the mean
distance is probably less, there is a
bigger outliers with FNO in this
particular case. And it's much more
dramatic when you go out of
distribution, right? Because here it's
uh almost everything is within 10%.
Which is but here as you can see almost
everything is beyond 10%. Right? It's
more or less all the samples are the
extremes are like 20%. But quite a lot
happens in this region right. So this
tells you that it's also important to
see what is the fidelity the statistical
fidelity across the distribution not
just uh for the mean values right
because the mean can still be okay and
you can have outliers. So here the
outliers the worst outlier is 10%
acceptable but here the worst outliers
are like 20%. Which I would say is
unacceptable and actually most of it so
if you take this the bulk of the FNO and
unit predictions certainly the FNO
predictions are beyond the outliers of
CNO. So in this particular case CNO
worked very very well. Okay. And these
are the kind of tests that we should do
ourselves in order to put your model
through the bases. You should check
check out of distribution. You should
check on different grades, different
types of outcome distribution. It could
be different times. We will see that
later. Or and you should check the
entire distribution and not just uh not
just a histogram. Let me show you a
couple of more examples. We have time.
So this is a very interesting one
because um
the in this case the frequencies are
somehow preserved.
So this is poso equation. Okay. So your
um
your uh equation is just minus lelassian
u equal to f. The operator is the
mapping which takes s to u. This is a
linear operator because when you change
u f linearly you change u linearly.
Right? So this is a linear operator.
Nothing fancy about it. My data is taken
from this uh 4ear series. Right? As you
can see these are the 4 year series in
two space dimensions. And there is some
decay. There are some random
coefficients. The coefficients are
uniformly distributed between minus1 and
1. And there is some decay. I don't
remember the value of alpha. I think it
is 0.5 or something. Okay. So in
distribution means k is going to be 16.
Okay. So there are 16 modes. This is how
the input looks like, right? Uh it looks
rather wavy. It's a sign input. But what
happens is that things get diffused out,
right? This is diffusion equation. So
these features get combined. They get
diffused out here. These guys get
combined. They get diffused out here and
so on and so forth. They get diffused
out here.
Okay. Uh now how do these different
architectures uh work on it? So if you
look at CNO for instance in
distribution, it does a very very good
job. It's almost exact in this
particular case. In fact, you can see
that the error is really tiny. It's
0.2%.
FN O we we have some understanding why
this happens but FNO does very very
badly on this particular problem as you
can see it it does not get it at all
right it has this bad features here and
so on unit also does a good job but FNO
is like 5%. U you could argue that
hyperparameters can be adjusted and I
know some people in Italy in Pavilla
they they did a very extensive
hyperparameter search automated
hyperparameter search and they found
some very very narrow hyperparameter
range where FN also did well but you
want to be robust with respect to
hyperparameters you just don't want one
particular choice of hyperparameters
that'll give you good results but what
happens when you test out of
distribution
of course now I even when When you test
out of distribution, it's quite
interesting. So the input becomes very
very wavy. The output of course diffuses
out. So again, CNO does a very very good
job. FNO completely gets it wrong, but
it had already got the in distribution
wrong. So that's not surprising. Unit
also did quite okay. Right on a fixed
resolution, it's sort of comparable to
CNO, but still it's the errors are quite
larger. So this is uh the usual usual
practice. But here the spectrogram is
very very interesting because now
remember that my my my system has a
finite bandwidth. It takes finite
bandwidth to finite bandwidth. There is
no approximation or there's no aliasing
error whatsoever with the operator. So
you can see that uh this is what happens
when you break the nuis barrier. Of
course cno starts failing but once the
nquis barrier is there it's a flat line.
Unit error increases quite a bit. Also
for FNO the errors are large as you can
see here the errors are reasonably large
and you can see why because it's a
ground truth in this case you know hits
the ground truth exactly because uh
frequencies are limited so it gets the
ground truth exactly both fn and unit
introduce artificial high frequencies in
these areas here here here unit larger
but also fn fo has also larger high
frequencies And it's precisely this
aliasing errors that can contribute to
this phenomena that you observe here. So
this was a very interesting example
because it sort of illustrates what is
going on quite well. Uh let me take a
couple of more examples perhaps and then
we we stop. Okay. So this is transport
equation which is a very simple this is
ut plus
ux=0. operator s is from u0 to u at t =
uh or something like that and all that I
do is that I move my my thing right so I
move it from here to here so again in
distribution everything is fine all of
them do a reasonably good job but out of
distribution is quite quite interesting
so for instance uh remember that uh co
is translation invariant so of course uh
when I've is translated my initial
vortex here. It learns the trans
translation very very well as does the
unit. Unit is also translation
invariant. Fn is not translation
invariant because the convolution is not
done in physical space in 4 spacees
nonlinearity. So it also introduces
something where it has learned something
before and that's why the errors are
very very bad but some of them are
really really bad. So if you take a
fully connected neural network has no
conception of space then this is how the
error looks like. It doesn't understand
that this is translation in invariant
neither does net which also does not
have translation invariance and then you
see the errors right. So even for the
simple examples asking some simple
questions about generalization tells you
what's going on. So let me finish with
our final example which is uh flow past
air foils.
This is not not that not that
interesting. You can see that different
architectures did quite well I think for
this example even though it's not a
cartigian grid but we mask the image and
you can see both in distribution as well
as out of distribution is captured quite
well. FNO again creates some high
frequency artifacts which are not
essential. So here the advantage is that
CNO or FNO the inference time is exactly
as before um 1 10,000th or 1,000th of a
second 1 millisecond or.1 millisecond.
Here on the other hand the finite
difference a finite volume solver was on
CPU so it took about a minute. So
already in 2D you can see that there are
there are some advantages that we have.
So this behavior is more or less across
the board. Okay, there are bunch of
equations here and it uh does the
learning quite well and uh yeah, so
computational efficiency is not that
important. But you can see that these
are different
model sizes and uh different sort of uh
time for the training time per epoch.
They're all comparable. They're between
3 to 5 seconds, right? So even if you
have a thousand epochs, it's 3,000
seconds. So you learn it within an hour.
So it's it's both CNO and FNO there is
no difference in in that sense. So okay
so I think with on that note we are
almost out of time today. So we stop
here and in the next lecture we will
test these models more. We'll find out
something very interesting about them
and we'll try to look at other kind of
models which are not just based on
convolutions because essentially CNO and
FNO they're both based on convolutions.
So we'll go beyond this and we'll try to
find out if we can we can do something
else which will be attention based. for
transformers but that is for the next
lecture. Okay. So thank you very much
and uh we meet next Thursday.